hello everybody markiplier here just
wanting to remind you guys that there is
one day one day until my promotion to
give away three free copies of
Borderlands 2 is over if you don't know
what I'm talking about
just click the link up here right about
here ish right here to take it to the
original video discussing the promotion
and also I will be counting shares all
the way up until about 6 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time at which point I will make
a V log just like this now I'll show the
bowl I'll dig my hand in it I'll put the
name up right on the screen I don't know
how it'll focus well but I'll try to
make sure that you guys can see the name
too so that it's not you don't you know
I'm just not biessing about it so keep
um today's the last year there's like a
little over 24 hours left if you want to
get your name in the Hat
the numbers are still pretty low there's
only been about 1,600 shares in total so
even in my last update a week ago there
hasn't been that much of an increase and
there's only about um 105 people there's
a few I haven't counted today so I think
there's a little over 105 people that
have submitted their name so if you want
a chance to win there are three copies
to giveaway of this pre-order and
remember as the video says up here all
the details are in here you could play
with me you get to play with me and do a
let's play with me and also the person
who shares the most also gets to do
another let's play with me in the future
so click here for all the details and
thank you guys so much for sharing it's
done an incredible job helping out
promoting the channel as you can
probably see we're at 6500 subscribers
that's a lot so thank you guys again for
sharing and working and helping out in
any way you can to try to grow the
channel because it's been incredible and
we're gonna go places real quick if we
keep this up so thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye